alright guys let's be honest Valerie
does a game that barely even exists yet
but it's already making waves and
breaking records I mean hell we even
streamed it for Kong no okay day with
the closed beta blowing up to which
we've already seen a ton of sick plays
and while it's early days yet and people
are only going to get better at this
game we still couldn't resist ranking
the top 10 valor it plays we've seen so
far starting off our list is the kind of
play honestly you can only find in valor
it a double jumping corn repeat that
shows up just how creative you could be
x QC uses raises blast packs to hop
right over the enemy stages slow field
and ball asked her in the corner she had
no idea what was coming okay guys number
nine is the only other Ray's play on
this list we promise but we just had to
show you this
just marvel at it one shot five kills a
perfect ace with one stupid broken alt
and enjoy it while you've got it because
Ray's is getting nerfed and this
disgusting alt will be gone by the time
this game actually comes out a number
eight on our list is the headshot
machine himself taking his skills to a
brand new game [ __ ] go man
now in csgo everyone knows that scream
is all about the one taps but over in
valor it things might be a little
different
let's go here scream gets the drop on
the attackers and gives them a taste of
jets alt before finishing them off with
the Vandal but hey don't worry he's
still got a one tap with bladestorm in
the middle of all of that one knife head
stab we've got to come up with a name
for this okay guys you're gonna be
seeing plenty of jet on this list and
there's a good reason why everything
this character does is hype and here's a
swan of Energy's apex legends players
showing us exactly why okay well
using jets mobility he pulls off a
creative flank to 1v3 the enemy and
single-handedly win the round let this
be a lesson when you're facing down an
enemy jet always look up coming in at
number 6 is the dirtiest wallbang in
valor and history and while that might
not sound so impressive you got to check
out this clip
[Music]
right there right there look people are
making a big deal about riots anti cheat
software but judging by this play it
might need a little more work like come
on if we didn't know better we'd say
summit is using wall hacks and is a vac
shot if we've ever seen one taking our
number five spot is the sneakiest valor
and play we've seen yet that's three
Brimstone's ability to play smokes just
about wherever he wants on the map can
lead to some pretty creative plays like
this one here from fours it smokes down
Molly
enemy remaining
my cover and see long with smokes forzen
gets the jump on the attackers leading
to a sneaky 3k to win the round at
number four is a play from simple that
shows he's just as good with the OP as
he is with the OP
now if there's one thing every csgo fan
knows it's that what simple has the OP
the other team is doomed and guess what
it looks like that's just as true in
valor --nt if you didn't know better
you'd swear you were watching simple get
this ace in CS it's kind of weird that
riot spelled the off wrong though right
I mean isn't there a W in there
somewhere
csgo players know all about pushing
their smokes but our number three entry
on this list should show you just how
crazy that strat can be and valor n't
[Applause]
here skadoodle was about to hit B with
brimstone but he lays down a smoke first
then he pops out and single-handedly
wins the round
you guys dude I said after a play like
that
there's really only one thing you can
say it's a [ __ ] yeah
taking our runner-up spot is a shroud
special so you like stylish Jets we'll
try five blind shots for a clean ace
[Music]
Travie pops jets alt then jumps out of
the smoke for one dances around his
opponents for three more including a
collateral and caps it all off with a
perfect snipe all the way down see long
I literally use my right-click on the
knives and got to their stack I was
taking the number one spot on our list
is once again skadoodle was here to show
us what Pete Valor --nt really looks
like skit daddy was in a one before
situation on B and it didn't even faze
him
and if you thought that was impressive
then he goes off to see site to pull off
something truly incredible
ska showed us what great players can
really do in valor it he didn't just
have perfect aim he also used his
abilities creatively to obliterate the
enemy team now nobody knows what pro
valor and will look like but plays like
this show that skadoodle is one of the
people playing at the highest level at
least right now well guys that's it
those are the top ten valor it plays at
least so far I cannot wait to see how
this game changes and evolves when it
comes out in the summer but until then
guys if you haven't already subscribe to
the score eSports and I'll see you next
time window windows rotating wall bank
knife round
haha it's a girl fashion gang fight you
know oh [ __ ] you win this you win did
you win these you win these [ __ ] is
happening you [ __ ] oh my lord my P
Valerie
lost my [ __ ] there for a second